if you win one Oscar you're good if you  win 2 you're greedy if you win 3 you're  Frank Capra here to present the award  for filming director Frank Capra  nominations for best achievement in film  editing come back little Sheba Hal  Wallis paramount Warren low flattop  monogram William Austin the greatest  show on earth DeMille paramount  Annie Balkans I noon creamy United  Artists Elmo Williams and Harry cursed  ed Moulin Rouge  Romulus United Artists Ralph Kaplan the  winner is the winners are  Elmo Williams and Harry ger stood for  High Noon  thank you thank you very much thank you  very much everybody enjoy thank you  ladies  thank you Frank Capra